chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that I run into might surprise
you whether I'm at an event or talking
on my podcast one thing has become clear
most people have no idea what a
self-made millionaire really looks like
you're going to get a glimpse into the
life of a self-made millionaire
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss it people this is
millionaire we weren't trying to be
millionaires we were trying to survive
[Music]
my name is Alan and this is my wife Pam
we've been married for 37 years and live
north of Sacramento in California my
father sort of rode the economic boom of
the 50s he worked for an oil company and
he turned out to be chief economist for
Union oil they were raised during the
Depression and that had a big influence
on them so they were very frugal with
their money and raised me don't ever
spend money save it for what I don't
know my folks were working-class my dad
was carpenter my mom was a teacher and
really didn't handle money very well at
all it wasn't out of ignorance if they
didn't have a plan never really talked
about money but we always knew that we
didn't have any money but you learn to
get by without my grandmother always
said you don't spend what you don't have
that create a lot of stress when we got
married at 25 I think I was overburdened
with concentrating on money rather than
concentrating on ourselves and our
integrity
so we struggled a probably our first
four or five years just understanding
what to do with money
I'm really turned off by keeping up with
the Joneses and having to have you know
a name-brand this a name-brand that and
I even shun that sort of thing I have a
make-do mentality like make do with what
you have we've always lived that even
with our boys money is a tool but it
doesn't define me my personal integrity
defines me and I think both the boys
have learned that this matter clothes on
your back it's person
so I started listening today with a
little bit over 20 years ago and
realized that we now could have a plan
so at that point I got serious about
organizing my finances and actually
wrote on paper but the plan wasn't to be
a millionaire the plan was to be a
successful person was the money that we
had you know whether you made $30,000 or
$60,000 we saved it every paycheck but
money in 401k and saved for college for
our two sons once the boys finished
college paying off the house would be
the next steps and again I grew up with
nothing so everything seemed like a
bonus most of my salary years have been
fifty to seventy-five thousand dollars a
year so I paid my taxes and pay property
taxes and paid for school with that
money so I think the misconception is
therefore I'm overstating what they need
to live on in retirement
would you agree yep i define retirement
as enjoying the opportunities with the
skills that the Lord's put on my
doorstep every day whoever shows up our
ability to give a my willingness to give
and our actual giving has just exploded
when people have a need in the past I
probably would close my eyes to it and
say well somebody else can take care of
that so it needs come up whether it's
people we need or people that we know
we're more than happy to help them
because we have the ability to meet
their needs
and whoever God puts on our doorstep is
today it's really made me see a lot of
the unlovely people that everybody
ignores and for me I am NOT going to
ignore those people and that may be a
little bit strange but that's my take on
on this is I have the resources help
somebody
why wouldn't I help somebody and it
gives me enough to teach my
grandchildren the same principle they
taught my times when they were young
it's a limited amount of time that you
have left to make an impact on people
that something wish everybody could
share you give any money regardless of
the money that they made in research if
you're willing to follow a budget month
by month and commit yourself to that you
can be a success now the variation is
how much you're saving that you will be
successful if you stay consistent month
in month out and dedicate yourself to
that I feel that very beautiful we are
all selfish people we're our own worst
enemy at times therefore consistent I
think we can all get this well just
watching him Keith worked really hard
and he had a lot of integrity and his
job he's educated himself on the way up
and something that I'm really proud of
and I think it's something that anybody
else could do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]